place on the 18th and 19th of april
it'll also air live on book tv
let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll be
happy to add them to our list email us
at booktv c-span.org
now on book tv an event from the museum
of american finance in new york city on
the origins of the board game monopoly
mary pylon author of the monopolists
refutes the commonly held history
promoted by the game's manufacturer
parker brothers that an unemployed
salesman sold the idea to the toy
company in 1935
so what the plan is is i'll talk a
little bit about the history of the game
and then open it up to questions and
answers so that way i'm not just
yammering and you can get some insight
on things that you hopefully will find
useful so this is the cover of the book
um so monopoly as we know it today most
people are familiar with this the little
red hotels the houses mr monopoly
the game most people if you talk to them
say oh parker brothers which is now
owned by hasbro they acquired the
company in 1991
and for years the story was that this
gentleman charles daryl invented the
game at the height of the great
depression and in america one of
america's darkest hours he goes into his
basement and innovates and he makes this
game um and puts atlantic city
properties on it as an homage to
vacations of during better times um
here's the original monopoly well the
patent from 1935 the monopoly patent you
can see it looks a lot like what most of
us know as monopoly today the tokens the
board the properties
um this is a version of this version a
version of the story has been on
hasbro's website for years
some people believe that darrow was the
inspiration for some of the early mr
monopoly characters the only problem is
that story isn't exactly true
the actual game originated with a woman
this woman elizabeth mcgee
so who was she
prior to inventing her game she actually
had a patent for a typewriter gadget
she was an outspoken feminist she had
a lot of views on this this is before
women could vote
um and her father was this gentleman
named james mcgee who wasn't just an
influential newspaper owner um but had
traveled with abraham lincoln during the
lincoln douglas debates and um was
around for the founding of the
republican party and was very impactful
on that lizzie mcgee also had appeared
on stage she wrote short stories she
wrote a book of poetry which you can see
the
plate there for that
um and she was very impacted by this man
henry george um so in this room i'm sure
a lot of people know about henry george
but a lot of people today don't and the
very very short version i am not a henry
george scholar is that he was a
proponent of single tax theory and he
had this idea that if you tax land and
only land the uh the working the working
class would have a better shot at uh
equality and he writes this book called
progress in poverty it is a massive
bestseller in his time you can read all
sorts of newspaper accounts of people
packing out halls to hear him speak he
was very charismatic and lizzie mcgee is
one of the people who reads this book
and is very moved by him and his
teachings
so here is her
patent for the 1904 landlord's game she
applies for it in 1903 she gets it in
1904
and
the idea of somebody taking to a board
game as a teaching tool may seem a
little strange to us today but at her
time it made a lot of sense board games
were becoming ascendant they were
becoming cheaper to manufacture
politicians were starting to talk about
the fight for leisure time so more and
more people as things like child labor
laws improve indoor lighting there's
just a lot more things that make board
games more conducive to the average
american as opposed to upper class
parlor games
so you can see the landlord's game
there are elements of her game that very
much carry over to monopoly today you go
to jail
she has a public park space obviously
cars weren't as big of a deal in 1904 as
they are now and she as a georgist was
very concerned with land usage
so she makes her game and it spreads
like wildfire especially among um
left-wing intellectuals in the northeast
so on the far left one of the earlier
monopoly players was rex tugwell he
later joined fdr's cabinet but was also
a teacher at columbia um in the center
you have um ernest angel who uh was a
national chairman of the aclu he had
been playing the game here in new york
and um his son roger angel is a writer
for the new yorker if you're a great
narrative sports journalism fan
um scott nearing plays the game he was a
professor at wharton who was involved in
a very
um important academic freedom case some
consider him to be the father of the
green movement so he was far ahead of
his time on that one he probably would
have gotten a kick out of brooklyn
um arden delaware is a single tax colony
where the game flourished and art in
delaware was frequented by scott nearing
a lot of other people including upton
sinclair and upton sinclair's house in
arden was called the jungle oh which is
a very ridiculous pun for you know as
his book was called the jungle and there
was actually this like really salacious
sex scandal that took place there but
maybe that's another presentation um it
was played at wharton it was played at
harvard it was played everywhere
so in 1924 lizzie renews her patent
it continues to spread as a folk game
she had been spending some time in
chicago so you see the loop and some
chicago properties on there
and one of the groups that really
embraces monopoly as a full game are the
quakers of atlantic city this is a
picture of a quaker monopoly night um
they had wooden boards people would make
these boards on their own and they would
add properties for whatever city they
were in so there were philadelphia
versions of the game there were boston
versions of the game um and this is an
atlantic city version of the game you
can see there
so here again we have a atlantic city
quaker board um this is the charles todd
board
uh as you look at this compared to the
lizzie mcgee game i showed you the
similarities between it and the monopoly
board become closer and closer so
charles todd actually lives in
philadelphia and he learns the game from
a friend in atlantic city
and he runs into some friends on the
street and
charles and esther darrow and he says
why don't you come over and we'll have a
monopoly night and which was very in
vogue at the time so the darrows and the
todds have this monopoly night todd
teaches daryl the game
and afterwards daryl asks can you type
up the rules for me and todd at first
thinks this is a little strange because
it'd be like somebody coming to your
house and you know you play checkers or
chess or a game that was just kind of
around and ask for a copy of the rules
but he does it anyway so charles todd's
secretary types up the rules and gives
them to daryl
so let's cut to parker brothers in the
30s for a minute in the mid 1930s parker
brothers was a firm that was completely
in crisis uh like a lot of companies at
the time nobody was buying anything uh
the balance sheet was a disaster there's
george parker sitting down there he had
founded the firm as a teenager in the
1880s and it was it was not looking good
his son-in-law robert barton who's
second from the left had just taken over
at parker brothers and was a lawyer by
training he had very little game
experience so he needs a solution and he
needs it fast
so
daryl starts selling the monopoly game
at wanna makers in philadelphia that's a
picture on the far left um it's still in
philly today if you were a fan of
mannequin the movie that's also where
that was shot and so daryl um and so
barton sees this his um
sally barton actually points it out to
him this monopoly game it's out there
and they strike up a deal in the flat
iron building which is where the parker
showroom was at the time and this is a
picture of barton he's a lot older here
and it's terrible quality photo but they
strike up this deal to buy some of
daryl's games
and monopoly becomes a monster best
seller parker brothers can't make these
things fast enough and the story of
daryl inventing it during the great
depression becomes a huge part of the
publicity campaign for the game
they actually um use darrow and his
image to make this game called bulls and
bears which you see on the bottom which
didn't sell well but there never had
really been a board game creation story
like the daryl story uh and he's giving
interviews a lot of press everywhere
so one of the things they need to do is
make tokens when the quakers were
playing the game they just used buttons
earrings miscellaneous objects things
that were around so parker brothers
calls on doused manufacturing
this company in chicago and what you
might know doused for is making cracker
jack prizes um and so a lot of their
tokens you can see some of them have
little loops
because they were originally made as
charms so if you were so even beyond the
cracker jack prize situation if you were
a company like the flatiron company you
might give customers like a little iron
token as like a tchotchke so um they use
some of those existing molds
so it's not long before parker and
barton realize they have a problem which
is that there are a lot of other
monopoly-ish games out there um so
barton writes to charles darrow and says
hey where did this game come from you
know can you give us a detailed history
of the game uh we might use it for
publicity purposes and this letter
exchange is in the book and i'll let you
kind of decide what you want but the
very the very short version is that
daryl kind of waffles and doesn't really
address the genesis of the game let
alone that it had been around for 30
plus years before he had sold it
so one of those games is dan lehman's
finance game when you look at this you
can see that it looks a lot like
monopoly and dan layman had played it as
a fraternity guy at williams college
and had sold it on his own so parker
brothers acquires it for not a lot of
money from dan lehmann and they start to
buy up other similar games that were on
the market milton bradley their rival
had a game called easy money a man in
texas named rudy copeland had a game
called inflation but they all kind of
mimic monopoly and draw their origins
from the landlord's game
but by then like by the minute excuse me
by the mid 1930s uh the daryl story the
train has left the station he's
everywhere hailed as the inventor lizzie
mcgee and her landlord's game are pretty
much forgotten
um lizzie's not happy about this um in
1936 she gives an interview this is from
the washington evening star
you can see her now she's an elderly
woman she's living in washington she's
holding up her boards and the monopoly
board that was on the market
and it says here that miss phillips
should have gotten married by then
it is understood she receives 500 for
her patent and she gets no royalties
probably if one counts lawyers printers
and patent office fees used up in
developing it the game has cost her more
than she made from it so that's the deal
that she got from parker brothers
so why did the patent office grant
darrow it's 1935 monopoly patent the one
i showed you
when mcgee had two similar ones before
it
we may never know
usually with a patent you have a thing
called the patent wrapper which is a
document around a patent that explains
to you
how how and where and why some of this
stuff happened
that's been missing for at least 40
years and i certainly couldn't find it
so we don't exactly know what happened
at the patent office
so mcgee and daryl died this is darrow's
obituary in the new york times hailing
him as the inventor of the game of
monopoly um lizzie mcgees is buried um i
had a really hard time finding it and
there's no mention of um monopoly here
or on her
grave and she didn't have any children
she died in 1948.
so how do we know any of this this whole
history was an accident and it came out
totally accidentally because of this guy
this is ralph onspock he uh this is a
picture of him in berkeley in the 70s he
was an economist he was teaching at san
francisco state at the time he makes a
game called anti-monopoly and it's not
long before he hears from uh let me back
up so he makes this game called
anti-monopoly because he's really upset
about the opec oil cartels this is a
picture of him and his son mark on the
left making this game uh he feels like
monopoly's roots are really negative he
wants to make it more philosophically
pleasing version of it
so they drop the game this is a drawing
that mark one of his sons had done it's
monopoly backwards and anti-monopoly
it's like very 70s um ralph nader and
the nader's raiders and like kind of
that kind of bent of public service
lawyer is very they're they're the
heroes of the game so it's not long
before he hears from parker brothers
attorneys saying you can't make
anti-monopoly we're the makers of
monopoly not cool
so that kicks off this 10-year long
legal battle um between ralph and spock
and his family and parker brothers
they rip apart all these different
aspects of trademark patent and
copyright law um and all of that's much
more detailed in the book
but as part of his lawsuit
onspock like everybody else thought dara
had admitted the game and he starts to
find out that the roots go back far
far
far far far back and he finds dan lehman
who's now an elderly man living in
pasadena and he holds up his finance
board he finds charles todd he hunts
down the quaker players
and i know this looks like organic
chemistry notes but it's actually
ralph's notes from trying to find these
photos of monopoly players and find out
who went to school with who who knew who
who was married to who and reverse
engineering the monopoly story from 1935
and winding his way back and trying to
find the thread between uh the 1935 game
and the 1904 lizzie mcgee patent and
then this is these are some of the
quakers a lot of them unfortunately
passed away even by the 70s when he was
putting together his case but they did
ultimately testify um
and let's see here so charles todd tells
him the story of meeting daryl that i
just told you
and he makes this point that he didn't
live in atlantic city he learned the
game from a friend who did um charles
todd lived in philadelphia as did his
friend charles darrow so if you go to
atlantic city marvin gardens is spelt
with an en because it's a combination of
margate and ventner um on the todd board
he makes a mistake and he spells it with
an in because he's not from atlantic
city i mean he doesn't he doesn't think
much of it and one thing that people
look at in um copycat cases when you're
trying to prove something like
plagiarism is if somebody copies an
error because what are the odds the same
person would make the same air twice um
and so daryl because he copies the todd
board
spells it with an in and charles todd
later jokes that it's the most copied
spelling error maybe in history that
every time he looked at a monopoly board
after you know he would think about his
his folly
um the color groupings are also
something that the court is very
interested in in the early monopoly
games
you can see that you know it's pretty
pretty substantial they're everywhere
ralph in his case tried to find a copy
of the board that had the word monopoly
on it um most people had testified that
they called it the monopoly game that
that's definitely what it was called pre
parker brothers um and then i actually
got this from a reader who found me
recently and said oh we have one in our
attic and i emailed ralph and i was like
well you know it took 40 years but these
boards did exist and there is actually a
surviving one so that's a picture he was
kind enough to uh let me use
so
this story is starting to get a lot of
press um the anti-monopoly case as well
as ralph um telling people that this
game existed before daryl and parker
brothers and there's this atlantic city
monopoly tournament
that parker brothers is sponsoring and
they're giving out this thing called the
darrow cup and this makes ralph seith
because by now he has pretty much ripped
apart this idea that daryl is the
inventor so ralph decides he's going to
set up a truth about monopoly lecture
next to the atlantic city monopoly
tournament and um the problem is that
parker brothers catches wind of this and
they reschedule these events and nobody
goes to the lecture but you wouldn't
know that by looking at this photo of
ralph in atlantic city he's very happy
to be there um but he had also heard
from
a couple of college kids at cornell who
had been kicked out of a monopoly
tournament and they were very upset
about this and they made a game about
how to win at monopoly that parker
brothers had you know attacked them over
and so there's another tournament taking
place in dc shortly thereafter so ralph
decides to join forces with these
college kids and they go about slipping
truth about monopoly monopoly pamphlets
under the dinner plates of journalists
which gets like a big rise out of people
and they feel pretty victorious about
this so that college kid was jay walker
the billionaire founder of priceline.com
and his his college roommate was jeff
lehman who ended up becoming the
president of cornell um and this is
their book and i actually was able to do
some successful ebay and amazon
squatting and get a copy and their names
are like on it and it's really funny
because it it actually if you want like
a pure how to play a monopoly book it's
pretty great um
so meanwhile in court parker brothers
wins an injunction and usually when you
have an injunction what you do is you
throw the merchandise that you're
arguing over in a warehouse and then
when the litigation is over you figure
out what to do but parker brothers is so
confident in their victory that they
decide to stage a burial of ralph's 40
000 anti-monopoly games so this is a
picture again the quality isn't that
great but a lot of these photos didn't
make it um where they bury the 40 000
board games in minnesota and mankato
which isn't far from where they were
being manufactured so at this point in
the case ralph is pretty deflated um
this legal battle went on for years it
strained his personal relationships um
his legal fees were really starting to
add up and obviously this isn't going to
be good for your self-esteem
um so ralph is victorious
in the courts in california but parker
brothers decides to appeal to the
supreme court and at this point ralph
needed a lawyer and he finds
carl pearson who actually is still
practicing here in new york city and um
he agrees to take the case on
contingency so it's the two of them
working out of carl's like tiny office
up against like a who's who of their
trademark lobby
but
the supreme court refuses to hear the
case and ralph wins and he wins his
right to produce anti-monopoly he wins a
settlement for his damaged games and he
also wins the right to talk about the
origins of the game he had previously
turned down a really massive settlement
offer that was a lot of money but he
wouldn't have been able to talk about
the history of the game pre-daro
but victory is not enough um he and his
friend russ foster who's there's a
bad quality photo here they decide they
want to try and dig up the games um
so they go to minnesota and they think
they know where they're buried and they
look and they look and they look and
they have no luck
and then somebody says you were in the
wrong place and ralph thinks oh well
sure we'll go back we'll go to wherever
they're buried and they they say well
you might have a problem they've built
condos
on top of
where the games are buried um and so
when people ask me you know why have you
spent all this time writing a book about
monopoly and board games which is a
perfectly legitimate question i
sometimes think you know someday those
games are going to get
they're going to be discovered i don't
know whether that's tomorrow i don't
know if it's 10 000 years from now but i
feel like we need a document to explain
why 40 000 board games ended up buried
in minnesota
so monopoly today i keep a close eye on
how the iconography is used and how
people talk about it jon stewart's
embraced it um if you're like into cat
memes which i am obviously it's made
some appearances there it's in gossip
girls and sopranos um i put this tattoo
slide up very intentionally because i
really want to find whoever has these
tattoos because i feel like if you're
somebody who has a monopoly arm sleeve
you're going to come to
some point in my you know like book tour
um but i think it's so ironic that it's
this thing that has become the total
opposite of what it really was which was
a grassroots left-wing political
teaching tool and it's been so embraced
as a symbol of big business
um so this is my book um you can buy
millions of copies of it and tell all of
your friends um and how to get in touch
with me if you have any other questions
but i think we're going to take some now
and i know i kind of sped through things
really quickly but
there's 300 pages if you want even more
so
let's take some questions
all talk at once
yes
so what was your discovery process on
this the history what led you to get
interested in it and uh start to find
out the back story
sure so this whole project came about by
accident i was trying to report
something totally different um this was
when i was on staff at the wall street
journal and i i've always loved games
and puzzles but i was gonna have like a
throwaway line about monopoly being
invented during the great depression and
it just wasn't adding up and it wasn't
making any sense and i was really
frustrated and i did that reporter trick
of calling somebody who had been
involved in litigation which was ralph
and i reached out and i said hey i know
this sounds crazy um but i'm a reporter
at the journal and i'm trying to find
out the truth about monopoly and i like
everybody had just assumed it was
invented during the great depression by
some guy and ralph immediately got back
to me and said oh i know all about the
history of monopoly and he just started
talking and i thought it was crazy um
and i think that sometimes as a reporter
you have you know everybody thinks
they're a deep throat and you take
people seriously but you're kind of like
you know like you get a lot of
conspiracy theorists you get so when he
started telling me this it was almost
the opposite where he would tell me
something and i would report it out like
the jaywalker piece for example so i had
to call up jaywalker and he was like oh
yeah send ralph my best you know those
were crazy days and so it all was
checking out
um so i wrote the original story and
then i met with ralph in san francisco
and he just had boxes of depositions and
documents and photographs and recordings
and
all this stuff that just makes like your
reporter soul like glow
and now they're in my apartment um
and so i started with those and then
kind of reported out from that so um
what a good example is um with lizzie
mcgee he knew she existed but i wanted
to know more about her and i actually
approached the first part of the book
like i was writing a mini biography of
her and researching somebody who died in
obscurity in 1948 with no kids is one of
the more challenging things i think i've
ever done and
you know as much as digital tools really
helped in the storytelling process so
archived newspaper resources from the
new york public library for example were
incredibly valuable um ancestry.com and
how they've digitized um genealogy
records and the census is incredible
like that made so much of this book
possible so like the quakers figuring
out what streets they lived on who was
near who um where lizzy was living at
different points in her life um that was
really really critical but there was a
lot of this book that wasn't digital i
think that there's i think his mindset's
changing a little bit but um i think
among a lot of journalists and a lot of
readers there's this idea that if it's
not on google it's like not information
like it's not real
and i kept finding over and over again
um
these gems that were just like in
people's attics or
um tucked away and thing i mean just so
much of this book was not out there
digitally um james mcgee her father um
this didn't even end up in the book but
his civil war letters were at the new
york historical society and so you get
the gloves and you paw through them and
you start to get a portrait of who this
guy really was and that so things like
that made these people into real human
beings as opposed to
textbook names so
it was a totally different process in
some ways from doing a newspaper story
because
most of the people you're in this case i
was writing about were deceased um ralph
was a huge resource and i've never
asked more of somebody in terms of time
in terms of walking me through
the timeline of how he found things he
had a lot of notes so he had documented
a lot of this really really well i
interviewed his sons i interviewed his
um his ex-wife actually passed away
there were three people um who who died
in the time i was reporting this so i
mean i i was like gathering as much as i
could um both interviews but then a lot
of things it was so frustrating like i
had so many moments where i thought like
barton why can't i just ask you a
question or daryl like what did you
think about this so
there was a lot of genealogy um
and uh but it was a hodgepodge of
everything and it was actually
overwhelming that was like the hardest
part was gathering all the string and
then actually putting it together it
felt very very unwieldy a lot of the
time
uh yes
so ralph must be thrilled
and i was wondering
um if there were things that you found
that he had never known
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah so ralph emailed me just a couple
days ago and his son
is actually a lawyer in new york and
wrote his harvard law admissions essay
about the anti-monopoly trial and how
growing up in courtrooms made him want
to be he's a labor lawyer um so i've
been in touch with them and ralph
emailed me
i was asking how he was doing and he
splits his time now between the states
and europe which is not a bad way to
live and he said life begins at 89 and i
just thought that was like so amazing i
was like gosh we should all be that
lucky to be so
spry in our 80s um but i did so the
lizzie mcgee pieces he found out he is
by far the expert on a lot of this and
he in the course of his case and he was
an economist before this i mean we were
dealing with somebody who had a very
sophisticated knowledge of henry george
and tax theory and kind of the context
of how it fit together um and he became
like a paralegal in a lot of ways
working on this case too
um but the lizzie mcgee pieces he knew
she existed but kind of the deeper stuff
and her biography was something i spent
a lot of time on
um and there were things that he just
wouldn't have needed to be interested in
so like the quakers and the history of
atlantic city that's in the book and
kind of what it was like for them living
there that was something i was much more
interested in
as a narrative storyteller
because he was living in berkeley in the
70s
it makes a lot of sense that he wouldn't
have had to zoom out and look at
what that meant what what did it mean to
be what was the political climate there
um so a lot of the character developing
um and a lot of those details were in
the depositions but they didn't make it
into the briefs of the court fight
because like they were interesting but
they weren't part of the the timeline he
was starting to put together so it was
really fleshing out a lot of the
characters and the lizzie mcgee in the
history of board game pieces the first
half the book was
a lot less reliant on those documents
see himself as part of this larger
history
yes and what i find so there's many
things i find amazing about his story um
but his conviction through the whole
thing i mean to turn down the settlement
offer which is a big turning point in
the book
um and he his background i i felt like i
needed to understand because the first
year or two of reporting this i had many
moments where i thought like why did he
keep doing this i mean it was straining
his family the finances i mean
hindsight's 20 20. i mean he won the
case
um but learning more about um his
background leaving danzig right before
the nazis came in
his life as an immigrant in the states
um was really important background and
when i was talking to his sons they were
describing their parents and they said
there was always a cause whether it was
rallying against the vietnam war or
anti-monopoly or
so yes he's you know he seems very very
happy but he's he was so secure in this
and he was so
confident after he'd pieced together the
story and i mean the supreme court case
ended in
1983. so he he's felt like the truth has
been out there for a long time um but it
is funny whenever um there's like a
mention in the news of like the darrow
story he's just like oh you know like
so um so yeah it's a long time to wait
to have your story told
yes do you have any contact with hasbro
during this yes i reached out to hasbro
i approached the reporting of this book
like i was reporting a long journal or
time story which means no surprises um
and you want as many people to
participate as you can so i had
contacted hasbro for comment several
times in the process and there was some
turnover and to be honest i'm not sure i
didn't follow like the play-by-play of
who was heading what part of pr then um
but i sent them hundreds of
fact-checking questions that weren't
answered um for the times excerpt of the
book that ran i contacted them they
didn't respond so um you know it's a
bummer when somebody doesn't want to
participate but um because they acquired
parker brothers in 1991 um i mean most
of the book takes place before then and
a lot of the documents um i was very
fortunate because i tried to give
everybody a voice in the story and
luckily barton had a deposition so i
feel like we did get to hear from him um
we have the daryl letters we have things
that um quite frankly i don't know what
documents they would have had because
they acquired the company so late so
even though they didn't participate
um researching the history of parker
brothers and the people was really
really important to me and a lot of that
because they were just such a noted
company was out there it took some
digging but but there was there was some
stuff out there
i don't believe so um but it's funny
because in the depositions there and you
can tell it's like a lot of lawyers like
there's that's a common typo that people
make and it really like i went through
the book like the night before it closed
and i was like i have to make sure
there's no clarence darrow's in here
like this is a book about charles darrow
so
i don't believe there's a relation but
who knows
um it's a relatively common
last name i believe
yes
and now you've seen a lot of how kind of
the history has been changed in terms of
how who looks to the creator of monopoly
what's really being done to honor the
legacy of mcgee
that's a wonderful question
um the short answer is i don't know um
she didn't have any children and um i
did my best to contact distant relatives
but by then they're so distant that you
know
it is what it is
um there isn't really anything tangible
like in place so after ralph's trial he
went about really trying to make sure
the quakers of atlantic city were not
acknowledged and he put up this plaque
and so
i guess i mean my version of it is just
telling her story
i mean it seems like most i can't even
tell you how many times the last few
years people go oh you're writing a book
a monopoly right the depression game and
i just i'm like uh you know it's like
it's so i i think that part one is just
getting the story out there but i don't
know of anything tangible if you have
ideas i'd be all ears
yes
i remember the anti-monopoly game in
sports back in the 70s we
that's a great question every now and
then i and i'm not like a game collector
or like a hardcore like appraiser every
now and then one pops up on ebay um
they're not if they're expensive they're
not like ludicrously so or at least i
haven't seen them um there was quite a
lot there was it was really successful
when it started so there were a lot of
them in circulation um so as far as i
know they're not really really expensive
um and in general board games are this
weird collectible because it's kind of
similar to what i think comic books went
through a generation ago where people
just thought they weren't valuable and
they were just you know people were
stuffing like plumbing leaks with them
and i mean which if you're a superman
fan just like you know makes you like
choke up um but uh i think board games
are cultural artifacts and i think they
are valuable and they do reflect times
that they were made in so i hope more
anti-monopoly games get preserved um and
he's changed it a little bit so so
they're out there but i almost wish
people valued them more because i think
it's a to me that's a game about
berkeley in the 70s and that's like
you know interesting plus the court case
i think it's very valuable
any other questions it's a very quiet
crowd i think has a big
did you look toy to see if it were any
of these old
yes they have a collection this museum
as well has a couple games that are just
right outside the door
um the strong museum um upstate has some
games um the forbes gallery actually had
a tremendous monopoly collection for a
few for a long time um including the
todd board around darrow board and then
they auctioned them recently so
um there was a lot of this was a couple
years ago there was just like a flurry
of email activity and people um trying
to because the the case in the history
is like very contentious um the strong
museum acquired one of those boards and
we know what they look like because
ralph you know gathered them and i have
photos of them and um they're you know
we know about them but now they're in
private hands so when i was in the first
stages of researching this book it was
amazing because i could go to the forbes
gallery just walk around and kind of
look around and compare things and kind
of get a visual sense of that but even
now that'd be harder to do which is
unfortunate
it's in rochester i believe yes
um and they have a ton of great stuff so
cheap jetblue flight if you're trying to
go
anything else nope
okay thank you so much
as it says up here a must read on sale
now the monopolist and mary be happy to
sign a copy for you thank you
thank you
[Applause]
every weekend book tv offers